hey youtubers it's Charlie so a bunch of
really cool news in the arrowverse with
flash and comic book stuff just dropped
that all you guys have been requesting
for a little while so I'll be talking
about flash season 4 Titan season 1 in a
new Deathstroke story because Madhu
Bennet's been going on and on about how
he wants a Deathstroke spin-off series
so there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so the really good news is that
the flash is confirmed to start filming
episode 1 for season 4 July 4th so like
literally four weeks from now they're
going to be rolling cameras you'll see
Barry walking around try not to be
noticed by cameras please everybody
forget Lee you saw me because I'm
supposed to be dead right now
but we also learned that the Titans TV
show is going to start filming their
episode 1 later this year - for 2018
premiere so Titans just to be clear is
not going to premiere till 2018 on the
DC streaming service but it's also being
produced by greg berlanti as DC group so
all the air over shows being produced by
greg berlanti crossover - a bearing
degree there's the new Black Lightning
TV show which is being shot in Atlanta
unlike Vancouver where all the other
shows are being done they've already
confirmed that he's not going to
participate in the four-way crossover
but they didn't say that he would never
a crossover with the other arrow vert
shows which is the big question for
Titans because the pitch they gave for
it is a group of young soon-to-be
superheros recruited from every corner
of the DC Universe so that could mean
anything but they're mostly talking
about roster they're saying you know
there might be a few non-traditional
people like cyborg might not be a part
of the TV series they've already
confirmed Starfire Raven Nightwing and
now Beast Boy Manu Bennett separately is
campaigning for a solo Deathstroke
series but here's where the crossover
Theory comes into play because there's a
perfect opportunity in a Lazarus
contract story that they just did in the
comics which would be a really easy way
to tie everything together even if you
want to have everything still be
separate so they can ignore each other's
continuity to a certain degree because
when you watch arrow you watch flash
they reference each other they really
only address big story points when they
have the four night crossover so for the
most part even though they're very
connected they don't necessarily
have to worry about what's going on on
the other TV show till they actually
sets it on screen together but the
Lazarus contract is something that goes
back to Nightwing's history when he was
still robbing fighting against death
stroke in the death of Slade's son so we
just heard about Slade's son on arrow
Joseph Wilson who's Jericho but he has
another son named Grant Wilson who
became the first version of Ravager
one of the biggest classic Teen Titans
stories of how Ravager gets juiced up
mirakuru style by hive in accepts a
contract to go kill them but in doing so
he gets killed himself Deathstroke takes
the contract from his son so Deathstroke
makes a bargain with Dick Grayson when
he's still robbing right after this has
happened he says I'll make a deal with
you I won't kill you if you'll help me
someday get my son back the reason it's
called the Lazarus contract is because
one is a twist on the Judas contract
which is a big Deathstroke Teen Titans
story but also two if Robin ever breaks
the terms of their deal Lazarus style he
can resurrect the contract that he took
out from hive to kill them cut to
present day you find out the Deathstroke
has this crazy plan to save his son but
in order to do so he needs to be able to
go back in time and steal the powers of
the african-american Wally West to do it
he tricks him into giving him his powers
the same way that zoom during flash
season to siphon Barry's powers state
forces leaving his body he's becoming
him
thus deathstroke becomes a speedster
this is what his costume looks like this
is his speedster costume it has this
gravity sheet that enables him to use
zero point energy to protect himself but
because it can manipulate gravity he can
also use it to bend time-space when he
runs so that he can travel through time
just like Barry Allen or Wally West
could so he keeps running back in time
to try and save his son grant willson
while the Titans in the Teen Titans are
all freaking out oh my god
Deathstroke has the powers of
time-travel he could snuff us from
existence
so it's a big WTF twist on the idea of
Deathstroke
trying to put his family back together
which is what he's trying to do as of
arrow season 6 that was the whole terms
of his agreement for helping Oliver out
in the season 5 finale so you already
have a lot of the mechanics and a lot of
the plot elements you would need to do a
Lazarus contract type story whereby
destro crosses over with the Titans in
the arrowverse characters at the same
time but you have to do a couple things
before you can get there you have to
introduce the grant willson ravager in
the Titans universe however the show is
going to deal with that character we saw
a version of him on legends of tomorrow
during season 1 in an alternate
post-apocalyptic future but what I'm
hoping is is that the Titans TV show
allows itself to sort of be
self-contained and at the same time
crossover with the arrow shows whenever
it wants to
which would just mean separate earth
you've already established the
multiverse on the flash so it's really
easy to just say hey this is all
happening on a separate earth so we're
not going to be talking to them every
single day wally west spent a bunch of
time the back half of the flash season 3
going to earth 3 to visit jesse quick
who was filling in for Jay Garrick but
even without all these really easy slam
dunk stories and pieces that they have
to fit together to make a really big
awesome Deathstroke crossover story with
Titans I don't think there's a very good
chance that Deathstroke is going to get
his own series just because they're
already doing Titans this year fact that
he's such a big part of those comics
she's making it seem like he's earmarked
for that show as well as whatever arrow
wants to use him for and I do think that
they're going to have to recast
Deathstroke eventually just because the
new Bennet will become unavailable or he
won't like the storyline that they have
planned for him like he really wants his
own solo series so what are what they'll
do is
use Deathstroke piecemeal on arrow
they'll do their own stories than
anything they do with the character on
the Titans TV show will be Titans based
Deathstroke stories they'll deal with
his family they'll introduce at least
one of the Ravager characters either
Rose Wilson or Grant Wilson
we haven't met Rose on the TV show yet
we only know about Jericho and Grant so
if you guys have read the Lazarus
contract story let me know what you guys
think of it I think they're doing a
fantastic job with all the rebirth
titles but Titans rebirth flash rebirth
are both fantastic even Teen Titans
there's a lot of fun too I'm a bigger
fan of Titans than I am of Teen Titans
right now but as we start getting closer
to the series coming out I'll start
doing more Titans videos there's just
not a lot of huge interest right now so
anytime there's big news I'll do new
Titan stuff believe all your requests
for bonus videos they drop - Gotham
season 4 promo so I'll probably do a
video for that next but they also
confirm bit Isis from The Black Adam
comics is going to be a character on
legends of tomorrow season 3 they cast
this actress so there was any question
Black Adam Shazam exists inside the air
over somewhere we just haven't met them
yet
so video on that coming in the next
couple days while you wait for
everything you can click here for more
flash season 4 and you can click here
for my Gotham finale video Batman Begins
everybody gets a costume thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight